[Musique]
jusqu'à un quart ou bien
à tous ses amis
je ne pardonne c'est par dunton donne
une barbe en deuil je te pardonne
elle adore ben ammar qui se passe son
coup de pub un joli pull que nous avons
c'est noël et christmas avant leur asile
et b retour et en plus ya tous les dames
c'est spontané merci mes chéris vive la
france
[Musique]
vingt ans merci bonsoir ramener la coupe
à la maison c'est le moment
à l'écouté du sucre d'orge partout chers
amis les vacances de noël arrive et vous
avez besoin d'avoir des bons chemins
kelly a surtout pour l'ol c'est
important ça en pharmacie mais on a un
code un code promo et avec le code vous
avez moins dû souvent pour sont ceux des
non sais combien c'est pas ton code max
10 eh ben vous avez moins 10%
bref -10% straumann a c'est qui celui
qui t'a envoyé grosse essai qui a
souhaité s'équiper et vannes surprenant
et battu repris gam noms cités qui va se
faire inquiéter créé envie de m pessah
qui ces gens là c'est acquis mais c'est
tout petit
[Musique]
beaucoup savent ce qu'il reste à faire
si l'année prochaine voulait manger des
crêpes
voilà
[Musique]